yeah let's view that
should be starting in just a second
there are eight people out there waiting
uh which is you know my my family and
kids
that's about
i can always count on them except if
there's another astrophysicist like neil
degrasse tyson on they prefer him
so today
we are joined by a past guest on the
into the impossible podcast and now i
can add to her many
accolades i can add
she is an author a published author
and she has always been an artist and
she has been an astronaut and all these
triple a
she's a triple threat in many ways and
it's uh nicole scott joining scott
joining us from the uh from the east
coast from florida right nicole yep yep
st petersburg florida and the call was
um i think you were my second astronaut
guest i had dr jessica myer on in
january of last year and that was really
fun because uh she was live on the
international space station at the time
yeah get any better than that
that's a pretty good get although when i
talked to her again she was in houston
uh at the end of last year and we
pointed out that's five times close
farther away than the international
space station right when it flies
overhead uh but last year you joined us
to talk about your
space for art and other projects and now
today we're going to talk about your
book and i just want to see if if people
are joining us on twitter i try to make
this
live on twitter i don't know if it's
actually going to work but we'll see if
it actually works
hop into the app okay so let's go to the
twitter app
and um
and let us
uh let us go on our phones and then
we'll just kind of or turn down the
volume as much as possible and hopefully
people will be able to hear us this
again as i always say it's an experiment
and many experiments fail but you you
always fail if you don't uh if you don't
try all right and i call
yeah so i'm going to start now and i'm
going to share it with a tweet
let's see here i'll share it with a
tweet um
my space
with
um okay so let me know i'm going to add
let's see if i can add you as a co-host
invite vm
oh look at that host
okay i see it yeah are you able to
i don't know
i see you and i see me up like at the
top of the
screen okay here i'm sending you a dm
um
i don't see you in the room yet
but hopefully you will be in soon
and uh people will let us know out there
in the
inner space of twitter we're talking
with an explorer of outer space today
there she is
okay just like the request going to add
you as a speaker i'm going to add you as
a co-host invite my gosh look at that
yeah yeah
all right so now the challenge is we
need to turn our mic our volume down on
our apps
really
and then keep it
keep it sort of uh available to us i
wish you could do this from there
from the app on this on the desktop but
i don't know if you can are people able
to hear us uh maybe give a reaction in
the twitter spaces if you can hear us
so i need to unmute on there can you
hear me now i hear you now yeah
okay all right and the last thing i'm
going to check is i just keep the phone
like in my lap and my
hopefully i speak loud enough people can
actually hear us
and i will see if we are still live on
youtube yes we are
awesome well this is a technology
technological challenge but i'm an
experimental physicist you're an
astronaut
artist and author of this fine book
back to earth
and the subtitle is what life in space
taught me about our home planet and our
mission to protect it
and i want to start as i always do
nicole
playing a game called judging books by
their covers you're never supposed to do
that but you know what else can you use
to to understand
what what a book is about so this is a
lovely book your publisher sent it to me
earlier of the year i've been just dying
to uh to get it in as many versions as
possible there's a link in the video
description below so please um
please click there but i wanted to start
off by asking you to describe how you
came up with the cover the title and the
subtitle
i think i'll start with the the title
and the subtitle if that's okay
um the title was something that uh
i think from the time i was starting to
think about writing a book um
that title was with me this whole idea
of back to earth
and
uh what it's what it really is referring
to is how we take uh
you know all this amazing work we've
been doing as of this international
community on the international space
station
and how we bring that back to earth in a
way that allows us all
you know to acknowledge our role as
crewmates versus passengers here on
spaceshipper
and um the subtitle what life in space
taught me about our home planet and our
mission to protect it
is really i think what underlies this
whole idea of bringing everything back
to earth which is
you know i mean one of the things i i
learned which i knew in kindergarten but
i will tell you it became reality for me
from space is that oh my gosh you know
looking out the windows like wow we live
on a planet
[Music]
that's you know it seems so simple i
know but i i don't know about you but i
hadn't really found myself thinking
about that you know really really
considering that on a daily basis right
and i can tell you after flying in space
i do
um
now i don't think that i learned
everything there is about the way our
planet works and all that kind of thing
but in how we relate to it
uh that's what i'm really trying to get
at and then you know our mission to
protect it
the it is bigger than i think the planet
the it is
you know recognizing that just like this
mechanical life support system we've
built in space uh you know to do
everything we can to mimic what earth
does for us naturally
um the it is about earth is our life
support system but it's about doing that
in a way that allows you know us and all
the life that it supports to thrive
excellent
now what i uh really enjoyed was uh
actually skipping all the way to the
acknowledgements you know i hate as an
author when uh
when a podcaster will ask me you know
what uh what's your entire book about uh
can you read the book uh can you can you
eliminate the need for my audience to
have to buy the book no no no we're not
gonna do that this book is delightful it
should be savored but i found the
acknowledgements
very very uh provocative and the
interesting way first of all they're
they're a couple pages long which is to
be commended
and second of all they begin with an
acknowledgement not to your family not
to the publisher
but to captain kirk
uh i want to talk about captain kirk
because i've been fascinated with him
for a long time long before i started
with him this past summer on unexplained
with william shatner
but uh but we're not here to talk about
me but uh i do have an imdb imdb credit
with him but i want to ask you um what
is uh he to you uh what is star trek to
you what do you think he's going to
learn when he comes back from space as i
understand he is going to space right
he is going to yeah he's launching the
space on book launch day next next
tuesday as best i understand if they
stick to their schedule and you know um
i don't know if it's about just about
captain kirk really i think
for me though my earliest memories of
anything sci-fi
you know as a kid
are star trek
and i'm so thankful for that because
you know star trek to me and i think to
a lot of people i hope is this
presentation of a future that i think we
would all
probably like to be a part of right
you know one that where earth is still
surviving and you know people are
thriving on on our home planet
and we are
exploring you know beyond our soul
the interstellar travel is happening
and you know for the most part that's
happening in a very positive way
and um
you know when i think about sci-fi
becoming sci-fact which you know i think
we see this happening all the time uh
things that were first just imagined in
some story somewhere
that we now you know i look at my phone
and i think about that
and um i i don't know i just think star
trek brought to light this this very
positive and encouraging
inspirational future yeah
absolutely
and to many people i think they'd be
curious um you know about how you would
expect him to react when he does return
hopefully safely to earth what what do
you think that will mean for him you
know spiritually psychologically
scientifically what do you think that
will connect the dots in his mind
well i you know i'm
so excited for all of these people that
are having this opportunity um first of
all if i had uh a chance to give him a
little bit of advice before he flies
i would suggest that
uh as they launch and when he gets you
know into that suborbital space and is
coming over the top of that you know
that parabola perhaps
you know that um
yeah loosen your belt a little bit
float up in your seat
but
from the time you get on board that
spaceship i want your face in the window
i don't want you worrying about flipping
around and throwing gel i don't want you
thinking about anything other than just
absorbing
this
um stunning
you know view of your home out the
window and trying to just just suck that
in um
to have it become a part of you
um you know i think about you know
william shatner is captain kirk i mean
all these adventures that they went on
you know the the places that they saw in
the universe the
other um life that they they met and
you know underlying all of that would be
what is the what is the home for anyone
of those beings you know what is the
you see the crew in their own ways
thinking and always engaging in
conversation about
where they're from and what they
consider home to be
and i want william shatner to
just really establish a new relationship
with with earth as a planet as his home
and and i hope that
by keeping that face in the window he'll
be able to do that and i think we all
come back after that experience um and
others even ones we have here on earth
you know with a call to action and i'd
like to think that he would be rallying
you know just like i am with this book
for
you know for everyone he meets to be be
crewmates you know find your role as
crew here not passengers
and
thinking about
thinking about how
he would react to it i also can't resist
mentioning the kind of real frequent
call out to
to the famous earthrise picture you know
where
kirk is going boldly away from the earth
but this book is focused on being on
earth back to earth and the life lessons
you learned as an astronaut i remember
hearing i was it mitchell or um uh i
think edgar mitchell i guess it's
probably him yeah so he says you know i
i just when i'm up there i just want to
take a congressman up there and say look
at that you son of a [ __ ] look at that
and i i kind of am depressed by that
nicole because i feel like
if it really takes you know people going
to space
before they get that impression uh you
know is is this book kind of designed to
have low-cost space travel you know for
the 1999 that this book is certainly
worth
can that replace that by getting your
honest perspectives on how it affected
you
personally cannot replace taking the
congressman
to space
well i i can tell you that i think every
every astronaut every crew of astronauts
and one of their conversations when
they're floating around the dinner table
you know during their mission this comes
up
now man if we could just get all these
world leaders you know their heads
bouncing off each other looking through
this window
and and i'm i'm going to be heading in
november to cope 26 you know in glasgow
and all i can think is man if we could
just lift these folks off the planet and
have them look back
at what they're talking about how
incredible how life-changing that would
be and yet
i really really don't believe you should
have to leave earth
to understand
this
you know this sense of an earthrise
moment this idea of the connection the
relationship we have to our planet and
to all life we share it with
you should not have to to get on a
spaceship and travel to space to do that
if you do get lucky enough to get on
that spaceship i hope to you know who i
mean i hope to god that you are
sucking that view in and letting it
impress you in every way that it
possibly can but you don't have to leave
the planet to do that i hope i hope that
the stories in my book and that the
people that i share who are doing such
incredible
crew member kinds of things already here
on earth
um we'll encourage everyone that reads
it to just i mean really take the time
every day to look around
and appreciate the awe and wonder that
surrounds you
every day look up look around look down
you know feel your feet touching the
planet you know and acknowledge that
and i think that that gets into you and
and hopefully it starts to impact the
decisions that you make and the way you
treat
you know everyone around you and the way
you treat the planet it's um
it's really a pretty
simple underlying theme of what we all
share in common
you make a very powerful case in the
book that uh as i've heard you know the
earth is in peril the earth is in danger
uh the earth's going to go on you know
with or without us right um
but the the question of what's in peril
is it us is it is it you know all life
on earth what is that cosmic perspective
that you've developed
well i think that's the you know it's i
forget which chapter it is and where you
know what page in the book that it is
but
um there's a you know there's an
interesting i think and you know like
darkly funny um excerpt from a george
carlin
skit but
um you know the bottom line is
you know earth's going to survive us
right
um
and the things that we're doing to it
right now that put our lives in jeopardy
the lives of you know the other
creatures we share the planet with in
jeopardy right what we're doing is we're
i mean we're impacting the things about
the life support system on this planet
that supports our life
and
the planet
you know we're like this blip right you
know it's kind of like when you're
talking about how much money does nasa
get from the government where it's not
even a line on the pie chart
it's the same thing with us right we're
not even a line you know we're barely a
faint little blip on the timeline of
this planet
and
um
you know it's survived worse than us
and and the problem is you know if we
don't address what we're doing to it we
put our you know the peril is for us and
for the other life we share the planet
with
and the time that it will take the
planet to recover may not support us
so um
yeah i think the peril is ours
and you talk about the you know kind of
this this false dichotomy or false
choice
that you know we we have to preserve the
economy preserve the environment um and
uh and they're sort of
incompatible and whether or not that is
actually a false dichotomy uh is is very
interesting to me uh and yet i often
find in in my motto i've in this channel
is one of my many mottos is you know
debate is pointless like it's very rare
you're going to convince someone by
arguing at them or with them etc um on
the other hand if you can ask sort of
what questions could it take to change
their minds or their perspective what
would it take to convince you
of x y or z i think what i'm curious
about is what would you most like people
to change their minds about after
reading this book obviously the fans and
the people that already agree with the
thesis prevent presented in this book
well follow along with it but those that
may be doubters i don't know i i hate
the word deniers i really refuse to use
it but but those that may be skeptics um
and maybe in a good way maybe not but
what would you say to them what would
you say to convince them that maybe they
should consider an alternative
perspective
yeah well i you know what you were first
saying at first about this kind of
conflict between economy and nature and
um
can they not overlap um i think that uh
you know one of the people i interview
in the book is mark tursek who was the
former ceo of nature conservancy
and what i love about well there's a
number of things you know one is he went
from being you know a vice president at
goldman sachs where his life was about
making money you know making money for
his clients right
and
he um was on a vacation with his family
and had you know one of those epiphany
perhaps earthrise moments
where in a very life-changing way he
discovered man i can be using these
talents i have
you know from the financial world to
look at the way we treat nature
you know and start to look at nature as
as a commodity with value
and that um that we should be and these
are his words you know we should be
protecting nature for us
not from us
right
um
i don't think there's anybody you would
meet
that would
would be opposed
to enjoying some natural setting would
be opposed to
having a nice time on the water
would be opposed to clean drinking water
you know i mean these kind of clean air
to breathe those kinds of things
and i think in the end what it comes
down to
is
um in whatever way it takes quite
honestly
um for us to help everyone establish
their own relationship
with um
with earth as our life support system
and that sounds a little bit weird
but
you know the simplicity of something
like where does this clean drinking
water that's coming through my faucet
come from
how are we maintaining this era that's
clean for me to breathe here and yet i
know on places on the planet that's not
happening and at some point that's going
to impact me yeah you know and and and i
honestly believe like you said um
you know pounding the fist
um
the
you know nothing but a scare tactic
um trying to guilt
someone into
you know changing their ways especially
if they
if they are comfortable and they don't
get a sense that that comfort level will
change
um that is that's that's not going to
work i think i think we have to
latch on to the things we have in common
um like
lift those up look for the messages of
hope that our scientists are giving us
us as well which they are i mean yeah
you know the headlines will be insect
apocalypse and yet
within that paper or that
expression of the science they're giving
us the solutions too right
and and we just need to figure out how
to um get everybody on board as
crewmates and
and i know that's an oversimplification
but it's incredible what we do is six or
seven people on a space station and i
want to know how that can parallel what
we do down here i want to talk about
that next but i want to remind people
we're talking with uh my friend and
former uh past guest on the show uh this
is uh astro nicole on twitter and she is
nicole stott i want to read her
biography she's the she was the second
astronaut to come on uh the into the
impossible podcast uh since then uh i've
had uh jessica my ear who was my first
guest live from the iss but uh she came
back in late december on earth
closer to where we are now and she also
uh was joined or followed by uh nicole
and then by dr scott parazynski who i've
invited to come to join us if he's
available dr scott is a friend of the
show and he kind of makes me a little
jealous because he's like my mom's
favorite guest that i've ever had and
she just loves them i i love him too but
i i get a little nervous would you
choose your mom's favorite guest not
your mom's favorite
ho stun
yeah that's yeah that that would be
embarrassing on monday or rather uh
tuesday we have um commander chris
hadfield on the podcast and he has a
book out called the apollo murders so
nicole do you have a uh a murder mystery
do you have a sci-fi fantasy do you have
any other books coming down the pipeline
after this wonderful book back to
earth um not myself i have some in my
mind that i'd love to you know love to
bring to life but um
nothing in the works yet i'm um you know
this is a
this is a pretty incredible process that
you have to you know that you go through
with the
kind of the proposal stage and this
you know manipulation that happens of
what the story is that you really want
to put on paper and then the
agent
publisher actual writing process and now
i you know i'm really i'm trying to
savor i think this you know having the
book come in the mail and hold it
physically in my hand and then know that
other people will be doing the same
thing
um
yeah i think i need to get through this
whole yeah
thing enjoy it yeah
promoting a book is as much work as
writing a book uh so nicole i was trying
to remind people she's an astronaut
artist and a mom
who spent over 100 days in space aboard
the international space station she had
a 28-year career with nasa and then she
founded the space for art foundation
we'll talk about that in a minute she
speaks to audiences around the world
including the vatican the u.n
at the uh historic paris agreement
and she is featured in national
geographic's one strange rock
and the painting that she created in
space is displayed at the smithsonian
air and space museum she lives in
florida with her family she's a speaker
and now she's an author uh really you
just do so much you're such a
renaissance a soul uh you really inspire
me and make me feel like even more of a
slacker than i actually am um you
mentioned before this crew aboard and i
saw the book maybe unintentionally maybe
intentionally as a leadership book
and um although you know there is no
like real hierarchy like you might have
in the military on this ship uh you guys
are having this motto that you talk
about in the book you know all for you
know earth essentially um talk about
this kind of hierarchical versus
non-hierarchical structure why does nasa
do it that way why do they um you know
and not have a commander of the ship you
know so to speak as the military would
do what is the underlying um benefit of
that and and maybe are there
consequences like it's maybe there's
efficiencies that are lost or something
talk about leadership in space
wow you know that's a yeah that's a
great question i think that um
you know as a crew um we do we do have a
commander on the space station
and you know the this is an this is an
international group of people uh you
know on board the station right and it's
one of the things i think is
like
its legacy um you know besides the
outstanding science that's being done
there will be the way we've
established and maintained these
international relationships where the
way we've brought five international
space agencies
representing 15 different countries
together you know peacefully and
successfully to this um
mission working off the earth for the
earth
and um so in this crew that's on board
the space station you know it's seven
people now i think is the normal size
crew it was six when i was there
we represent all 15 of those countries
even if there's not somebody up there
from you know one of those five agencies
but
there is a commander and they rotate
that through like each of the different
countries you know in some way at some
point gets a commander role on the space
station
the rules of engagement are all in place
you know with the teams on the ground
about how problems will be resolved and
and and somehow you know this is another
thing that just stands out to me somehow
the heads of all these agencies and the
people that run them
um were able to i'm imagining sit around
a table or you know through some video
conference
um able to establish these rules of
engagement that
while it's not always you know um
uh
flowers and
you know happiness they they have a way
to work out the issues
and that then translates i think to how
the crews work together on board
with a commander
knowing that in some some ways there is
a hierarchy there you're
you know how you have all of your flight
engineers and your commander
and and yet
um
the day-to-day action on board that
station is with
everyone understanding their role
um with the tasks that are sent to us on
the schedule with the way we work
together on those the communication with
the ground
and and all of that and it's a pretty
rare thing where the commander either
has to
you know take some overarching action or
communicate with the ground you know
independent of of the crew
and i think that's because the you know
these ways that we work with each other
have been just established so nicely
that it just flows and we train together
you know we train together um in some
pretty challenging situations we go out
into the wilderness and you know
discover each of our own strengths and
weaknesses and how we're gonna
uh balance those in
succeeding at the mission
um
we train in every emergency situation
that
the ground team can consider might
happen to us
and it's incredible how
uh when you get to space
the way you trained comes to life and is
just like this effortless
motion of six crew members floating
around the station coming together to
solve the problem and whatever the
humanly
possible way is to do that
and i think that was one of the things i
was most proud of um
as a crew was seeing that happen you
know when the emergency alarm is blaring
at three o'clock in the morning
and you all float out of your crew
compartment and the for you know you're
like okay
um
don't leave a don't leave a crew member
behind you know you're accounting for
all your crew members everybody's
getting to the place where they know
they're supposed to go to deal with the
emergency they're doing it and then
you're you know you kind of chill
afterwards and you're like oh my gosh we
just did that
in a way that was probably there's
probably no better way to do that
and you could be really proud of that
kind of thing we can and we can rally
the same way here on earth
for you know for any emergency alarm
that's going off i think we have the
the ability to do that we have to find
the will i think to really come together
yeah
and one thing that you know has united
the planet
you know for better or for worse in some
ways uh is of course the covid
uh pandemic and that actually i remember
affected the astronaut crew obviously
they were completely isolated the most
isolated people on earth there were
similar people above the earth the most
isolated people on earth were at the
south pole where i've done some work
but at the uh above the earth were the
denizens of the iss
yeah
talk about how you know that experience
and perhaps the lessons
uh of you know kind of space flight and
and crewing and leadership um and and
also the side of fear which i want to
get into next a topic of courage fear et
cetera um you know how does that play
into your thought process now and and
maybe within the realm of of even the
nasa philosophy itself if you would yeah
uh you know as this whole last gosh it's
almost two years now this whole well
let's not go there yet no this whole
year and a half that's gone by where
you know all of us
you know all of us were put into
and and all of us is all of us like you
know the all the earthlings right um put
into a very different situation than
than we're used to
and you know as that was all going down
um
you know my family and i here in
florida you stayed
as close to home as you possibly can do
during that time we tried to respect all
of the again you know the rules of
engagement that were in place to keep
ourselves and
you know everyone around us safe
and i found myself thinking about that
you know that isolation that happens to
crew members on board a space station
um that just separates you from the
planet um
and
you know the things we do there to stay
connected
i found myself wanting to do here you
know i wanted to know that i had a way
to communicate with my mom and my
sisters and my in-laws and my friends
and to
even maybe more actively engage that you
know to make sure they were doing all
right um when you couldn't physically go
be in those places with those people
i found myself
looking out my window and you know
spending time in my own yard in a way
that was like man
there's there's awesomeness and wonder
around me you know even in this place of
of isolation and the same is true on a
space station you know you get your face
in front of the window and you get
sucked into that view and then you know
you got to set the alarm to remind
yourself to go back to work it's a it's
a transcendent kind of thing
so i was
hopeful and tried to share with the
people that i know
and through some media stuff too because
we were getting asked the same question
you know how do you how do we leverage
these kinds of things in us to you know
to to stay healthy to stay connected
um
and i think
i think you're right what we just saw
and are still experiencing
around the world and the way
humanity generally rallied right
you know we had people staying in their
homes and coming out
opening their windows and singing with
each other right they couldn't get down
in the street and be together but they
they made these connections the kind of
these human connections they found new
ways to do that when you couldn't
physically be in the same place with
somebody
and um and it became really important to
do those things
and it became important for us just like
with some of these other challenges we
have
to acknowledge
the science behind it right that sounds
so simple right
you know let's
you know you and i have have some
respect for science and we want everyone
we know to have that respect and
you know and to to leverage it in a way
that can can lift us out of these
problems that we're having
and and i i i can't speak for you but i
have to believe that that
that you know
we have all the technology we need
to solve the problems that we have on
the planet right now yeah we have people
some of them in you know in this book i
wrote that are already implementing
those things you know and trying to do
so in a on a planetary scale
and um
we just need to be put you know putting
ourselves in a position where
regardless of what country you're from
which you know curve on the planet you
you know live in
you know this is this is our one shared
home that we have to
um come together to
you know protect for the sake of all
life that we share it with absolutely
um i do want to remind listeners that we
are going to take questions in just a
little bit after i am done
yammering away with my uh questions for
nicole um i will be happy to take
questions from the vast audience on
twitter and on youtube and i think i am
also broadcasting to um to linkedin
we'll see if that ever works never tried
that before or it's been a while at
least uh so nicole and i talked last
time because i'm a parent and you're a
parent um and we talked a lot about
about courage and fear and i remember
being really just leveled and and
affected by your statement that you
never really feared for yourself and it
was always sort of um more of a fear
for your son and and what would happen
god forbid right um talk about that i
want to read uh
just a quick um
uh statement that i found and i think of
you whenever i read it let's see if i
can find it it's a quote from uh from
c.s lewis let me see i put it on here
okay c.s lewis wrote courage is not
simply one of the virtues but the form
of every virtue at the testing point try
living in with moderation try being
honest try pursuing knowledge try doing
any of these in a world that has
forsaken wisdom self-discipline and
justice and see how far you get without
courage you'll be mocked um i want to
know do you feel courage is kind of the
opposite of fear or do you feel like
they are not necessarily even on the
same spectrum of emotions
well you know
that's a difficult question um you know
the fear thing in the way that you
described it yeah i mean for me
and i think this is true for
i'd like to think this was true for my
my colleagues my crewmates is that
um because of all that training we just
talked about you know where you've
you've
discovered all of what we know to be the
humanly possible things to overcome the
the problems we might have and
figured out how to wait to work together
to to implement that i think you feel
prepared to deal you know to deal with
what um what might come during the
mission or as you're getting there or
coming home
you know and that's not to say that we
don't understand that there's risks
associated with um
with what we're doing to get to space
live there and work there for even a
short period of time and come home
it's just that um
i think within the realm of what we can
do about any of it that might go wrong
we we feel comfortable
there is a total respect
for you know for the of kind of the
overall risk of of this kind of thing
but
um
yeah i found myself feeling like man i
on the launch pad worried about
uh
my son and my husband watching me
and and i think that's where i thought
about courage like how you know how
courageous is this seven-year-old to be
able to stand and watch his mom
you know launch on a on a rocket and um
you know to be there with his dad doing
that and
and you know i we have to give our kids
credit i mean they understand what's
going on around them you know a
seven-year-old gets what's what's
happening when a rocket is launching and
you know and what that might mean for
you know for his mom that's on board or
for for his family for him
and um
so
that
at the same time i'm thinking there had
to be a
he had to be feeling fear as well but he
didn't
run from it you know he didn't
leave his dad standing on the launch
control center you know roof watching it
alone um
he he stood
by my husband
in a way that
i think speaks to how the rest of us can
you know deal with the things going on
around us that we shouldn't you know run
for cover when different difficult
things are happening in front of us
right
and and there are difficult things
happening in front of us on earth right
now on our planet and
we can't be running for cover we have to
find you know what is it in us that will
help us stand and
you know take the action we need to you
know to recover from whatever it is
you mentioned the frequent you know kind
of tropes leveled against nasa that i
think are based upon the fact that most
people
overestimate nasa's budget by you know a
factor of a thousand um at least what do
you make of nasa's brand i claim it's
probably the most powerful brand you
know in terms of investment to return on
investment and that i see people you
know walking around with you know nasa
t-shirts and hats and
everyone's fascinated with space and uh
from the world's most successful
billionaires that are competing for
nasa's partnerships like elon musk and
bezos and branson
but
talk about the nasa brand is it is it uh
is it on the way up is it is it sort of
being burnished properly what do you
think about the stewardship of the nasa
brand is it is it better than ever or is
it sort of maybe living on the fumes of
glory from when you were in the active
astronaut corps no i think actually i
think it's always getting better and i
think it's you know you mentioned like
you know seeing people in a nasa t-shirt
i was just in dubai and there were kids
with nasa t-shirts and they knew what it
was it's not like oh somebody gave them
a t-shirt and they just wore it i mean
they knew what it was they wanted it
they were excited about it
and i think that has happened everywhere
i've gone on the planet you see you see
some of that i mean i get i get uh even
when i was in the office astronaut
office and even now i'll get
requests for autographs
from places that
you know you you you just can't imagine
a
space being a thing that would be
thought of
and it is and i think nasa represents
all of that
um i'm also a um
a firm believer in the fact that um
you know nasa right now and always i
think has done a really great job
um
primarily communicating to people that
already love nasa
right and and where it's starting to
improve
is in addressing the audiences that
might not even know there's an
international space station and that's
where i think you know you know more
work um
things that i'm happy to see happening
um happening are
it needs to continue happen we need to
be reaching out to
the communities the audiences that don't
know there's an international space
station don't know that we have
um you know this plan to go back and
settle on the moon permanently and why
you know the bigger question of why we
would do that why that's valuable
they don't know that everything that
these representatives of 15 different
countries
on the space station are doing up there
is ultimately about improving life on
earth
and that's the kind of messaging that
needs to get out more and more and i'd
actually like to see that coming out
more and more from
the names you mentioned like you know
the bezos and the bransons and the musks
you know there's some of it there but i
think underlying all of them their
motivation is very positively about how
do we improve life on earth
whether that's multi-planetary species
kind of thing or lifting industry off
the planet to
you know a benign environment in space
you know all of those things are about
are about improving life on earth
uh
next i want to turn to uh two of your uh
very closely held causes that i know
about from our previous conversation
last summer
which is has it having to do with art in
space and also women in space
first let's talk about how you painted
this magnificent painting in space
i'll have a link to that in the video
show notes
but how do you actually paint a
watercolor like i i could maybe spray
paint some graffiti on the side you know
tag the side of the iss i'd probably get
kicked off but um how do you paint a
watercolor i mean that's almost
impossible to do in in g let alone zero
how does that work yeah watercolors are
difficult just you know to make it look
like what you want it to look like right
you know it was really fun and i think
um and we might have talked about this
before but i really gosh i wish i would
have activated my brain cell to
videotape the whole experience of
painting with watercolors in space
because
i think it would have been such a
wonderful way to just
describe what it was like to live in
space in general right you go up there
the expectation at least in a
microgravity environment is that
everything's going to be a little bit
different right you know no matter what
it is um how you wash your hair the way
you do science you know the way you move
it's all a little bit different
in a microgravity environment doesn't
mean it's more difficult it's just
different you know and you got to think
about it like it's part of the adventure
so painting in space with watercolors
was certainly that you know it
it like was full evidence of how
everything floats you know you're
floating your brush is going to float if
you let go of it
you might lose it um
and you don't have a cup of water to dip
your brush into so you've got to like
squirt out little balls of floating
water
to dip your brush into and because of
the way surface tension behaves in space
you know even before you get the tip of
the brush to the ball of water it's
moving like it's like it's attracted to
and wanting to move on to the end of the
brush and float around it and
you know then you mush it on the color
you know the colored paints and bring
that colored ball of water up and all
the time you're having to be really
careful
to transport that ball of water to the
paper now because if you move too fast
it's just gonna you know splatter all
over the place and i would get in
trouble just like you spray paint in the
side of the space station you know i'd
get in trouble if i was splattering
watercolor paint all over the inside of
the space station it might actually
might look kind of cool but um
and just the whole like process of it
the the difference in the way the brush
and the paint and the water behaved was
just a really special part of it and you
know it i think brought like the
creativity in it to a new level because
you were having to do it differently
to try to
i don't know paint a painting of
something you'd seen out the window
and
um
i don't know the way i think about it
people look at my painting they'll
probably think okay what kindergartner
did that you know
but
um any in the end i'm not really worried
about whether somebody likes it or not
right
i i want them to look at it and it's
like what we were talking about with
nasa i want them
to engage with me in the back story like
you know what was the subject that where
were you you know i could talk about
being in this place
you know where we're doing all these
things off the earth for the earth and
and perhaps engage somebody who didn't
know about what we're doing in space in
a way that
you know that they're wanting to know
more
and um and i i'll tell you i have
experience where you know you talk to
somebody about
that app you know spot the station app
where you can put your
zip code in and it'll tell you when the
space station is going to be flying
overhead and where you can watch it come
from and travel to to the other horizon
and
that just
that's so attractive to people i think
because it's another way
right to establish a relationship with
this place that you might not have known
anything about
and then as you watch that dot of light
moving across the night sky you're like
oh my gosh there's
seven people on board that space station
representing 15 different countries
somehow for over 20 years working
peacefully and successfully in that
place and oh my gosh look at that you
know and you do you establish a
relationship with it
and it's kind of like painting in space
you're going to talk to chris who played
his guitar and sang
on board the station um
you know other astronauts since the very
beginning have been doing creative
things in space and i think it's because
we
we want to bring our humanity with us
it's it's a difference than sending the
robots right we want to bring human we
want to put the human in human space
flight and i think that's a really
that's a really compelling thing to
think about as we're exploring further
and further off our planet
and
establishing these relationships and
knowing that everything we're doing
needs to be coming back to earth
for the benefit of all life here
so we're going to take some audience
questions in just a minute we have some
on youtube we have some on twitter
spaces
um i have some questions from my own
family i want to take one more uh
opportunity to
discuss a topic that i know is near and
dear to your heart not just this week
which happens to be a special week that
you can explain to folks the uh what is
the nature of this week's international
space week as designated by the un and
how does that play a role in the lives
of potential uh female both uh
astronauts and non-astronauts uh 35
as i understand it of the astronaut
office is female uh compared to 13
percent of the engineering workforce in
general so by you know just numbers it
won't appear three times as good almost
uh but uh what what's you know what's
left for there to do and what role do
you see yourself and others playing
during this week which uh october 4th
through the 11th international space
week what participation is ongoing to
ensure to reach the broadest panorama of
the human intellect
well i think that you know like world
space week first of all with a women in
space theme you know the the w and wsw
is world so the
you know the the audience is
international and i've already
participated on several different uh
you know panel sessions with other women
um you know india europe uh
africa that have have these events going
on where
i think the key in all of it and it's
what we need to continue to do and i
think is what has
allowed us to engage and and invite to
encourage more women young girls to
participate in these kinds of um
of fields is being present for them
right and and that's what's happening
during this week um during all these
sessions you know really incredible
women from all kinds of different
backgrounds
in space um you know not just astronauts
and and and in the end it really isn't
all about the astronauts
you know they we we tend to be the this
this kind of focal point for things but
everything
that's being done to get us to space to
do the work in space you know that's
really the the valuable most important
part of what's going on we we're like
the implementers of it right right the
hands of the scientists whatever until
that day when we can actually be
sending the scientists themselves you
know i'm take me on that flight with you
please um to do their own work on the
space station or on the moon or on mars
or wherever else it might be
that that we are traveling in space um
but i think the key is this this
presence um especially for young girls
i think and i have a son who
is now 19 just started college you know
god bless him um
and i watched at school how
the boys reacted on career day right you
know it didn't matter to them if it was
a man or woman standing in front of the
classroom talking about something
they're just looking at it like oh my
gosh is this cool is that something i
might want to do and you know and
thinking about it that way whereas for
the most part and while i don't like to
stereotype anything for the most part
young girls are looking there and saying
okay you know they're looking for
somebody
similar to them they're looking for
somebody that kind of represents them to
say
that might be possible for them
you know sadly um
so we got to be there you know we've got
to be out there
um being present and i think that's
going to continue for a while and i hope
there's a time where we're not talking
about having to
you know um highlight women or men in
space because we're we're needing to
encourage them to be there that it's
just
you know
a mix of humanity happening and you're
right and the nasa astronaut office
you know 35 plus percent
you know female representation now
across the human space flight program
you know those numbers are probably on
par
and yeah you can tell the
um
you know how we encourage
women to enroll in programs at
universities
somehow we need to be getting them
better in the middle school time frame i
think being present then to
you know encourage them to keep um
pursuing keep aiming aiming higher and
there's a really wonderful event going
on in
atlanta this weekend um in parallel with
world space week and with international
day of the girl and supporting
uh the upcoming artemis mission you know
the themes behind the artist
mission where you know nasa is looking
to put the next humans on the moon of
which
that will include the first
you know female astronaut and person of
color so
lots of great things to look forward to
in space and i think it will encourage
other other industries as well so we are
going to take some questions from the
audience and we have one about uh
presumably uh from somebody uh who
either has a healthy dose of
self-confidence or his parents uh picked
a name that i was going to choose for
one of my kids prince charming
who wants me to ask you about space
elevators i guess this would be a way to
reduce the cost you know to nothing once
you build the elevator i suppose um what
is uh what is your thought about the
ultimate reduction in the cost per pound
to take uh items to space uh using a
space elevator is it feasible
yeah i you know i
in all honestly i don't know if that
that will be feasible i there's a lot of
um
minds greater than mine that are are
looking that and kind of evolving the
idea of that technology over time
um i think the
in in the end there is there is
feasibility to it um i think they've
shown that it's more about how do you
what are the protections you put in
place
um with respect to how that elevator is
deployed right you know how do you
protect you know already when we do
launches we have this range control
system right um
that
you know clears out boats and planes and
everything from the surrounding area for
where you're going to launch a rocket
and protects in case there is an
accident what that you know debris field
might be in the surrounding area and so
that same kind of thing is going to have
to come in into play and perhaps even
with with a lot more thoughtfulness when
you talk about deploying something like
you know a thin line
um that's gonna
you know
go between point a and point b a on the
planet and b someplace in space and how
do you manage that both physically and
um with respect to
what could happen with it right
uh next we do have on twitter we have a
request from
josue i guess i'll make you a speaker
and twitter spaces remind you you can
ask your question on twitter or type it
in on
the comments live chat section on
youtube
hello yes joe you're you're up on stage
please go ahead
[Applause]
did you get that um
[Music]
uh i think so but but
brian repeat if you if you think you've
got a way to yeah i think the question
is you know do you think ultimately the
the sacrifice
for getting both you individually and
humans as a species to get the
cosmic perspective as past guest neil
degrasse tyson says um do you think it's
worth it it's an awful lot of money um
and what do we get in return is it worth
it for us integrating over the entirety
of uh of our species
uh yeah i think so i think there's a i
think we could talk all day about this
quite honestly um there's there's all
different kinds of levels of this um
you know one being uh
this what you just said this cosmic
perspective this um in the words of
frank white this overview effect this
this
sense of who and where we are in space
together even though you know we should
know that without having to travel to
space
but um i don't know of anyone that has
traveled to space and not come back to
earth with
with
a little bit of a shift with um
you know something life-changing for
them that
really drives it's it's like a call to
action it's
a need you know not just to share the
experience that you had but to put you
know put something to work um
you know that's meaningful that um
encourages other people to you know to
do things that are meaningful to you
know
again for the benefit of all life we
share this planet with um so
that alone you know in addition to the
fact that as humans we are going to
explore we're going to do it you know
with
um i and i think regardless of what it
will cost
um
but
um and i won't get this this totally
right but i think this is this is
something interesting to me um and my my
husband who is like the sci-fi expert of
the world but
um
author and i would say philosopher larry
niven
has a quote that's not um
typically attributed to him a lot of
people use it and and don't um maybe
even know where it came from but it's
something like you know if the dinosaurs
um had had a space program they wouldn't
got us gone extinct
and and if we don't have one it'll be
our own fault
so
um again i think all of what we're doing
at
a relatively in the grand scheme of
things low cost
to explore space to bring those lessons
back to earth
is something that we just will need to
do from here on out and you know this
multi-planetary species thing that we
talk about in terms of taking ourselves
you know humanity continuing
um you know at some point the sun is not
going to be so kind to us right and if
we're still just here in the
alone in the solar system
um you know just going to mars isn't
going to save us either so we've gotta
we gotta again we gotta bring that star
trek reality to life right
that's right that's where we began with
uh with captain kirk who boldly went
where
no
human had been before and uh i want to
close again with this wonderful theme
that runs throughout this truly
delightful book and we're speaking about
back to earth i'm going to have it
floating here in zero g
uh it's it was it's such a it's such a
delightful read it's full of images of
nicole i have the hard copy the kindle
copy
um and i will get the audio copy i'm
sure because uh because of that is the
way i like to do things this book really
does um convey on a personal level i
think you know people when they say oh
an artist or you know it's just a mother
i mean nicole is hardcore i mean you're
one of the toughest badasses that i've
ever known and it was funny because your
publicist didn't know that you'd already
been on the show and she's like would
you be interested i was yes
i saw nicole yes this is like six months
ago so thank you i love this book so
much back to earth it's the story of
what life in space taught her but really
what it teaches all of us about how our
home planet and our mission to protect
it is so vital and so crucial and you
have a theme that runs through the book
and i just want to close with that um
this theme off the earth but for the
earth what does that mean to you now
that you're on the earth
is your perspective forever changed
absolutely and um
you know that's that that off the earth
for the earth it's the motto of the
international space station and
um my friend and
astronaut classmate and crewmate um
kevin ford
coined that um as on his mission patch
when he was getting ready to fly to the
space station and the space station
program loved it so much that like oh we
got to keep it we got to keep it for the
the program as a whole because i think
it's so
it's just so beautifully um fits
everything we're doing in space and
and the whole point is to bring it back
to earth is to take the lessons we learn
there about how we work together about
the science that we're you know
investigating um to improve life on
earth
and and everybody should know about that
and everybody should take that as
i mean my hope in in reading this book
is that people really will they'll
they'll read it they'll reflect on what
i experienced but they'll make their own
connection their own relationship to the
stories and
they'll discover their own way their own
call to action to behave
like crewmates and not passengers here
on spaceship earth
oh it's truly delightful and it's
delightful and uh really an honor to
talk to you
uh nicole stott who is as i say a hero
she's just so genuine easy to talk to we
didn't geek out about aviation this time
i refer you to my previous conversation
from last year with nicole
last summer which was uh really a
highlight of my podcasting career and i
wish you great success with this and i
want to encourage my listeners to buy
this book and also to stay tuned on
tuesday we'll have commander chris
hadfield on for his new book the apollo
murders it's so scary but it's
appropriate for halloween month right
nicole
yeah absolutely and i'm i'm really
excited about that you know chris
chris's book apollo murders mine back to
earth and then you need to get eileen
collins on with you her book please
would connect me with all three
launching on october 12th with william
shatner captain kirk going into this
position
we have an abundance of astro explorer
authors if you would put me in touch
with eileen i would be forever i would
be happy to do that and i want to again
thank you and encourage folks to tune in
uh and do you have any questions you
want to ask chris because he's my next
guest on the show any questions for
chris i i'll i'll ask him after he's on
your show
nicole thank you so much for joining us
please everybody follow us
in person yes i know i'll be in florida
maybe early next year so we'll be in
touch maybe we could do a live a live
episode in the follow up that would be
fun that would be fun and thanks to all
the listeners really appreciate your
your support
it's so much read the book yes get the
book listen to the book read the book
change your perspective on the universe
thanks everybody have a wonderful
weekend and i will see you next week
with commander chris hadfield discussing
murder most foul and zero g bye bye guys
thanks nicole
you